[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to four bar
part three in this video I'm working on
mostly a dome for the island but before
I do that I'm going to be adding some
smaller things around the fronds here or
the back I'm not actually sure which
side of the island is which but some of
the smaller things which I haven't got
so far on the bottom of the island just
to start cleaning up that stuff already
I'm not entirely sure what I'm gonna do
on the bottom of the island to make sure
that it stays in the air I might put
some propellers down there or I might
put some like air bubbles in there we'll
see whatever I can do with that but at
first I just want to clean up the sort
of messy spots that I left over here
before I get into the dome building
which as a fair warning at the beginning
of this video while we are still freshly
into this video I do want to say that I
took about well well over 15 minutes to
make the dome and that is even with
parts cut outs and so it's going to be a
pretty slow-paced
part it's definitely going to be the
outlandish and overly detailed and
slow-paced kind of building that I was
talking about at the beginning of this
series so that's something to I suppose
prepare for just keep in mind that
there's not going to be happening too
much in this video but my focus is
really again on getting all of the
details in and experimenting a lot with
the different pieces that we have and so
over here I'm just kind of cleaning up
everything making sure that if I leave
this part of the island behind there
aren't any messy bits or open bits which
kind of look unfinished and rough so one
of the things that I was very concerned
about was how to actually control the
enormous gear which I have over here
this is the issue with making this
island in general is that there are so
many different parts which should be
moving and which are going through each
other we have the coaster track moving
through a lot of the building we have
the enormous gear which basically
disrupts any kind of fluid building that
you want to have
throughout that area and I'm going to
make sure that I have these parts where
these different moving parts can
basically go through each other without
too much friction so I'm building that
quick trench for the gear to go through
and that'll also be sort of cutting
through a building as well and over here
underneath the coaster I wanted to
support the flying a propeller tower
that I have with a arch that juts out
from the rest of the building so that
the lift Hill supports are still mostly
visible and I don't end up putting the
building and a cursor too much too close
to each other but still it looks
somewhat alrights
I suppose I also wanted to get something
that you know connects the propeller
tower to the rest of the building and to
the ground so that it isn't floating by
itself while at the same time making
something that's lightweight you know
that it doesn't form this enormous wall
meaning that you can't see the rest of
it which is basically why I wanted to
choose this arch piece and then for sort
of the foundation of that I decided to
put this little slope over here which
kind of follows the curve of the island
that's definitely something that I want
to do with the rest of these buildings
as well I do want to leave some of the
island visible so their work there will
be some sort of trees here in there a
little bit of foliage but also some of
these parts where the walls just kind of
go along with the shape of the island so
not everything is flat sand static and
boring and instead even the the down
side of the building should be
interesting to look at I figured and
much like an interesting foundation or
podium for a building I didn't want to
give these slightly different textures
so whereas I am hoping to have most of
the buildings tool parts or used as very
light brick texture and very light
stones in general I want to make sure
that the foundation parts have much more
dark tones so I'm using many of the same
pieces over here just in darker shades
of brown
and again I do kind of mix up the
different shades to make everything
stand out a little bit from each other
the only thing that I'm still concerned
with and this is something which you
know I'm not really too sure yet how
it's gonna work out because the island
is so vastly unfinished and there isn't
any foliage or anything gets in there
but the one thing that I'm very
concerned about and not sure how it's
gonna work out is really the color
scheme in a sense that it's is very
brownish it's very gritty and of course
that's part of the the steampunk
aesthetic as well in a sense but it
almost feels like it's two colorless
like everything is very toned down and
blend and that's something that I do
want to avoid and I'm not really sure
how because so far I do have many of the
same shades of brown only only way in
which I kind of want to counteract that
is how with these super dark spots like
have some of these elements like the
weird random steam machine over here
which ideally the idea would be that
this is you know the bottom of the gear
and this is where powers the gear
because the gear kind of like the ferris
wheel adds that is built around the
Thunderdome what's it called again
Thunder dolphin in Tokyo which is super
interesting it's a ferris wheel that
doesn't actually have any support it's
just completely supported by the lower
part of it saying that it doesn't have
any supports it's kind of yeah that's
kind of a misconception I suppose it is
of course opponent isn't floating but
it's it's a ferris wheel without any
spokes and thunder dolphin the roller
coaster goes straight through it and
what it does is it kind of holds up the
ferris wheel and just pretty much
controls the entire entire thing from
down at the ground level and that's kind
of what I'm doing with this gear that's
an overly ridiculous explanation could
have been perhaps a bit easier but if
you didn't know about the ferris wheel
yet you should totally check it out
because it is awesome and it's actually
what and one of the ingame ferris wheels
is based on but anyway that's why I
wanted to have that machine down there
at the gear and my original point was
that yeah I wanted to have some of these
very dark colors here in there so some
of these spots do have some super dark
brown or even black little elements
to hopefully make everything a bit more
contrasting and not too blurry but I'm
not sure how well that's really going to
work out in the end I suppose we'll see
once everything is done anyway that was
all I wanted to do for the small details
now moving on I am finally stunning the
work on the dome and I'm gonna have to
fill 15 minutes of this so we'll see how
that's gonna go I suppose a very good
point to talk about now that were still
making the very beginnings of the dome
is what my inspirations were because my
inspirations were very crucial in how I
made the outline of the dome and that in
turn was very crucial to how it looks in
the end of course so this is a pretty
interesting thing basically my first
initial inspiration was what else the
the st. peter's basilica dome ends in
vatican city which is absolutely
beautiful and has definitely been an
inspiration for many domes around the
world but also there is the beautiful
marble church in copenhagen which has
this a similar dome just with different
elements that i thought was very good
kind of reference not really reference
in any way but a good kind of estimate
of the kind of thing that I was going
for this is gonna be a very large dome
very dominating and much like those two
domes have all of these pillars on the
side have a bunch of windows on top of
the dome and a pretty large cupola on
top of it so that's really why they were
such big inspirations in terms of many
details though I am not really doing
what either of them that are doing and
in terms of color that is definitely not
the case I started out with this green
copper ish colour hoping that I could
turn this into an interesting green
copper dome in the end I did skip that
idea though because it doesn't really
fit in with the red roofs that I have
for the rest of the castle I was
originally thinking that this green dome
would be able to add some more color to
the otherwise just using warm colors
castle so kind of offset the
large amount of reds and browns that the
Casso has so far but I think in the end
it just doesn't really work that well
I'm just the bigger fan of this dome
with a red roof so I changed it to red
in the end but that's not really a big
deal the basic shape of the roof or of
the dome is basically like this and the
shape is really just arrived from st.
Peters and the same kind of goes for the
idea to add these little windows in here
though you see those in domes very often
in terms of the design though they are a
bit interesting just a bunch of
improvisation with the new pieces that
we have I am super glad that we have all
these new pieces because while I'm not
really messing around with them too much
this is my first time opening the quark
file of opera with the Christmas pieces
and some of the gingerbread pieces are
super good for iron work and that's
something which I really missed in some
of the later episodes in or some of the
earlier episodes I mean I remember in
episode 1 and 2 I would have to sync
like signs and things like that into
walls in in very like ridiculous ways to
end up with that little part of iron
work at the end of the object that I
would use for my own iron work but in
this case making these gingerbread
pieces blank is just a beautiful way to
use to make your own iron work basically
and using them in a sort of beige kind
of color kind of works as stone
decorative elements as well definitely
that's a bit of an Art Nouveau vibe to
me as well so that was just what I was
experimenting with at this point nothing
too good or anything just really
randomly trying these objects on the
windows and seeing how it would look but
it's it's just those little little very
small decorative elements that do add a
bit of flair to buildings and definitely
make them a bit more unique because of
course not every building is going to be
exactly the same in details even if it
is the same in general layout so I think
these smaller pieces are really what you
can make different buildings in planet
coaster more unique with and standout
with more
now for the ridges of the dome I sort of
had a couple of versions of this as you
might be able to tell my first version
was just simple pillars that didn't work
out too well so then I went to some of
the smaller concrete page pillars but
still those felt very thick and so in
the end I was looking for more of a
connection with the red roof and a way
to make these ridges look less thick and
put more of a focus on the color of the
roof itself and in the end the way that
I tried to achieve that is by just
putting these red decorative elements on
the side of these and that is basically
that they are some of the things that
brought the amount of objects in this
building up to some quite ridiculous
Heights since in the end the dome alone
I think has somewhere up to like 6,000
or 8,000 pieces something like this it's
it's not very good for my computer
that's for sure but that's why I'm doing
this in a separate pipe file anyway but
it's it's not very user friendly I would
say and it's definitely not something
that I can even think about uploading to
the workshop sadly and so the dome part
of the dome that sounds weird is pretty
much finished at this point and I wanted
to get to some of the sides where I
wasn't too sure how to approach this
there are definitely different ways I
just wanted to have like some sort of
cornices at the top part and then just a
very wide part without anything in it's
just decorative elements and then
underneath that some pillars that hold
up the rest of the dome so here I'm just
adding sort of like the white decorative
and cornice parts and one of the things
which I thought was kind of funny is I
want to get some some of these draped
clothing parts that you often see on the
classical buildings it's more a very
classical piece but there isn't any such
piece in the game there are some of
these pieces for actual clothing but of
course I needed them to be cut out of
stone in this case as well just took a
door and
bunch of Christmas decorations and I
kind of looks like it especially from a
distance I suppose it gets the idea
across and then I wanted to get to some
of these small spider parts and I
figured why not do the spire of the
propeller tower very quickly because we
do have these new Christmas what do they
call them baubles I believe that was
probably the worst pronunciation ever I
did check all of the comments when I
talks about a word earlier in my
Christmas series but um I didn't
actually look up how to pronounce the
word so thank you for everybody who left
a suggestion for how I should pronounce
it though I hope that was okay
but anyway I put some of those on top
because as great as there can be in
Christmas trees it's when you call it
these things and give them a different
purpose is when they really shine I
think especially on some of these very
small decorative elements and then to
make the piece which rests on top of the
pillars and I did have to do a bunch of
Tryon error with this piece because
while the piece itself is very simple
it's just a part of what you see on many
freezes in classical architecture just
very large in this case the only problem
that I had with this is that I wasn't
really sure how much I wanted the
pillars to stick out from the rest of
the dome because for Saint Peter's
Basilica for instance the pillars stick
out from the dome a lot like they really
make the building appear a lot wider but
in many cases the pillars are more like
the Lester's and they're just kind of
tucked into the wall and don't actually
make the building wider at all and so at
first I tried to make these like pillars
that really stick out from building and
half this parts come out and make it a
lot wider and in the end I did have to
experiment a bit with how much I wanted
this point a stick out for the
proportions of the building to still
make sense but the basic premise is
fairly simple like kind of like custom
pillars because the the game doesn't
actually have any round pillows that you
can make yourself which makes a lot of
sense the pillars in became are very
easy to use but in this case I was
looking for an exact color and textures
that are
looking for so I put a bunch of square
pillows together rotated them until they
were round which is actually a good
thing because pillows especially
Corinthian pillows like these have deep
bridges so dragging a pillar around to
make a round pillar out of the square
pillow kind of gives you those ridges
that you want to have in a classical
pillar so I've got that and then some of
the regular crowns that you see except
also kind of rotated to make them a bit
more round and that's really the pillars
they're one of my favorite things I know
this isn't the first time I've used them
but it's the first time that I've
actually talked about them and talked a
bit about how I make them they're just
some of my favorite things because even
though they might not be too great on
your object count for the pillars you
are just using rectangles so that really
doesn't add too much to your leg of the
game
I believe shouldn't be too much of an
issue plus you're not placing too many
of them either but it gives you a lot
more control over how your pillars look
how tall they are what kind of colors
they have is that something that I
really love doing now as for the final
parts of this video which is making the
cupola on top of the dome this is
something that I struggled with quite a
bit since so far the dome was really
just built on some dimensions that I set
at the very beginning of the video where
if I copy around this dome it's gonna
seamlessly fit into each other to have
this one section become the entire avoid
the entire dome all the way around but
for the cupola I had no idea like what
to make the dimensions out of to make
sure that I could copy/paste it make it
go round and turn it into a full dome so
at this point it was a bit of trial and
error to get this thing in the right
position but the basic premise of the
thing itself is just very similar to the
dome except at a very small scale I made
some extra small pillars over here I had
to make my own crunch for these though
because the in-game ones are super small
so I decided to pick a bunch of cornices
not too many but just a fair amount in
that it looks like a Corinthian
I crown with all of these leaves
sticking out from it so yeah I took a
bunch of those and make my own ones
which are a little bit smaller than the
in-game ones and definitely have the
wrong shape that I was looking for but
then when I was copying it around I
found that the dimensions were
completely off and basically meant that
I would fill on the entire thing with
just pillars and no open space between
that so I sort of had to rethink my
plans at this point I thought for a
second to kind of do it like this where
I have separate pillars but I wasn't
really too happy with how that looks
either since the rest of the pillars on
here are all double pillars so in the
end what I did is I made the piece of
dome that I already have underneath here
twice as wide so that I have to copy
paste two times less of these things to
make the full dome which means that I
have twice the amount of width to mess
around with the small cupola over here
if that makes any sense basically it
means that I can put these two pillows
next to each other and all the
dimensions are going to work out rights
and the space between the pillars is
going to be just a little bit more than
the space that the pillows themselves
take in so that's all fair and at that
point I was pretty confident to go into
the top part of this thing here which
again kind of mimics the bottom part of
the dome wanted to make sure that at
least it's somewhat similar and whether
these things have like a pointy roof or
at a very small dome roof I don't think
it really matters too much but what I
did want to make sure was that the top
parts of the cupola here is very tall
and it it really is kind of like a
vertical accent so what I decided to do
in the end is sort of put like a mini
cupola on some of it again and have that
be topped off by a very small spire
which is just gonna be pyramid shaped
ish except with eight sides I'm not sure
what the mathematical name for that is
and instead of that idea which I tried
earlier which is just a solid roof I
decided to make this actually fit in
with the main tower of the building
actually keep some
themes that repeat throughout the build
so I decided to make it out of the same
wooden posts that I met the top part of
the tower out of which is like the
tallest the main tower of the building
which come has that light Eiffel Tower
ich parts um so now we have this sort of
brown rusted ish metal looking part on
top of the dome and that's something
which I'm quite happy with it's not the
best looking thing but it's a way to
keep that theme repeating throughout the
build and make it fit in a little bit
more with the rest of the build because
um oh wow that was the weirdest
pronunciation of build ever and put the
rest of this entire thing already has a
lot of these steampunk gritty industrial
like elements like the main tower has
all of these pipes and stuff coming outs
there are a few gears here and there
there's definitely some machinery and
steam engines around the island but this
dome has none of that stuff at least not
yet
it's not something that kind of breaks
away from the rest of the theme of the
island and that's something that I'll
definitely have to figure out how to
deal with that at some point in the
future I just didn't want to end up
ruining this dome
so what I'll most likely end up doing to
make it fit in a bit more is for one my
plan for the next episode is to build a
enormous clock custom-made to give it
kind of a clock punk idea in there and
put it into this the steampunk theme bit
more lots of opportunities for iron work
over there as well I know maybe maybe we
will put some cables in pipes on the
side of this dome and decorate it in
this episode I just wanted to get the
dome itself in and so to top it off here
I just quickly make the spire parts and
now we can copy the entire dome together
as a big test to see how this thing is
working and in the end it all connects
beautifully and that is basically it so
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]